hallo mein name ist luca höre hier ist
kürzel dicker jetzt lukas 3 hallo hier
ist patrick kunkel marktzeit und auch
ich haben auf dem youtube-kanal von
tahir ein riss entdeckt bei denen man
anhand von drei gegebenen merkmalen den
bestimmten youtuber der hinter diesen
drei merkmalen steckt erraten muss darf
in norditalien ist jetzt 2 crysis gipfel
ich zeige meine vier davon hatten bisher
zwei größtes gemacht ich mache heute
mein video hier den teil 1 und max hat
auf seinem kanal 2 2 gemacht das heißt
den link zu max wie fertig in der
beschreibung check das auf jeden fall
aus und abonniert max der ist kurz vor
500.000 aber nicht
ihr seht mich jetzt wahrscheinlich in
der kleinen fenster eingeblendet das
heißt wir kriegen jetzt einfach mal auf
play bei dem video also erkennst du
diese youtuber an drei merkmale
natürlich bosch in frage natürlich
erstens hochwertige blogs plus spielkind
plus groß ich mal kurz auf pause das ist
ja eigentlich recht easy hochwertige die
loks hätten ja so viele sein können also
in amerika casey leistet macht
unglaublich kasse wieder beziehungsweise
hat unglaublich kassel wie jobs gemacht
hat ja leider aufgehört zu bloggen aber
in bezug auf den deutschen raum weil wir
da in fünf bis zehn kanäle einer war
dann halt spielkind eingeblendet hat war
es halt schon klar ich würde mal sagen
dena das heißt ich jetzt einfach mal
noch weiter ich glaube das ist jetzt
noch kurz genau jetzt kommt hier gleich
zeichen und es war denen dieses game im
zweiten
[Musik]
bini mütze plus vegan plus longboard
okay das ist eigentlich auch recht easy
ich weiß nicht ob er die bienen willst
du noch so häufig trägt ich mein
mittlerweile hat er ja auch gar keine
rastalocken wer mal nicht aber vegan und
longboard ist eigentlich klar also ich
würde sagen simon unglück jetzt kommt
das gleich zeichen und wir haben simon
onkel für sein mund okay die ersten
beiden youtuber war enorm easy ich hoffe
das bleibt nicht so wie sie aber da
kommen auf jeden fall auch so viele weil
das videos gerade eine minute lang und
wir sind schon beim dritten dritter
youtuber den wir heute erraten wollen
ursprünglich aus hamburg plus für bis
plus 2 minuten
[Musik]
das ist jetzt echt einfach gerade und es
kommen dass gleichzeitig meine damen und
herren und wir haben als youtuber paar
luton der da irgendwo vor dem grill
setzt auf irgendein bekommen der vierte
youtuber die berappen müssen 90er jahre
fanboys hochwertige kurzfilme los mythos
er war lehrer
[Musik]
ich würde sagen herr bergmann ich weiß
nicht was es mit mythos er fahrlehrer
auf sich hat oder mit 90er jahre fanboy
aber hochwertige kurzfilme denke ich mal
direkt an herrn bergmann daher das ja
doch sehr gut kann und der youtuber der
essbar ist herbert mal
bisher haben wir alles richtig leute ihr
könnt ja auch mal einfach mit raten und
mit immer in die kommentare schreiben
wenn ich auf pause drücken was ihr dann
denkt wir rauskamen der fünfte youtuber
ist ein trio zwei deutsche ein türke und
hatte nicht viel in der vergangenheit wo
ich bin mir nicht sicher ich denke halt
wenn bei trio irgendwie immer nur ein tt
2 deutscher ein türke kommt auch hin
weil es ist ja glaube ich auf der türkei
hatten nicht viel in der vergangenheit
kann ich nicht einschätzen also ich weiß
es nicht ich würde sagen wir klicken auf
weiter eigentlich gibt es ja einen
solchen noch gar nicht so viele trikots
also ich glaube es gibt ja auch enorm
wenige die einfach ihren kanal allein zu
zweit betreiben oder so die meisten
haben ja eigentlich einzelnen channels
frag dich drauf kommen können okay
bisher habe ich von vier youtuber nur
noch drei richtig packen aber genau das
gleiche einfach auch mal zieht die zu
gepasst glaube liebt pizza plus eins
streitig ist sein markenzeichen und auch
gross war ich da hier das ist einfach
die pizzeria gepackt es kommt dass
gleichzeitig meine damen und herren und
es ist außer sich selber im sommer quiz
zu sehen jetzt kommt der sind waren der
siebte youtuber schon dann habe ich von
sechs youtube fünf richtig okay wir
sagen weil er ich habe bisher nur einen
falsch dann muss ich nicht die ganze
komisch mitzählen zwillinge
bloß eine krankheit plus etliche
musikvideos ich würde sagen die lobbys
bei mehr zwillinge gibt es ja eigentlich
in deutschland nicht also natürlich gibt
es in deutschland zwillinge aber die
halt auch youtube machen und sowohl die
lotto ich bin sowohl der achte youtuber
ist eine polin war mit einem youtuber
zusammen und ist eine biene ich würde
sagen da geht also ich wusste nicht dass
die polen ist die war auf jeden fall mit
laien zusammen und bekommt ja glaub ich
klar ist ja logisch weil es einfach so
ihr markenzeichen ist so da gb und
bietet mit dem ist der englische
übersetzung von biederen da haben wir
sie auch da gibt auch erraten meist
dislike das video deutschlands besitzer
dreistelliger sneaker und früher call of
duty videos ich würde sagen apo-med
store for me concerning des gaming ein
angebot für das schiff wurde durch
prince bekannt ist ein ausländer und
nachname klingt französisch finde ich
boah ich würde sagen leon masche der
nachname klingt auch wirklich nur wegen
anbaus gefunden wurden wir warten noch
das gleichnis ist leon marschiere ich
weiß nicht ob er wirklich der name
wirklich französisch ist noch darauf aus
frankreich kommt aber ja ich habe es
richtig [ __ ] ist nach amerika gezogen
für schwarze hautfarbe bloß der name
englisch wird englisch ausgesprochen ich
denke wir sind uns alle einig dass es
seine des jungen ist das hätte ich auch
schon nach jetzt nach amerika gezogen
sagen können viele youtube hat das so
gesagt ja aber muss man nach amerika
ziehen er hat zu wenig gemacht da sehen
wir gerade eingeblendet seine des juwi
er irgendwelche bürger frist mit call of
duty videos angefangen ist dünn und
barcelona fan park ich kenne wenige call
of duty spieler als sowas halt scorpion
ist zumindest nicht weil der will ich
glaube es ist besser wenn denn der ist
dann kann ich mich wirklich schätzen
dass ich zumindest ihnen dann auch gerne
von call of duty
es ist meine damen und herren das ist
sehr stark damit wieder richtig erraten
wir kommen direkt zum 13 youtuber und
zwar hat er die merkmale führerschein
signal nicht besteuert es ist ins großer
dem fitness freak und macht sich oft
über andere youtuber lustig kommt denke
ich ist also es ist 10 milliarden
prozentig in skopje ich weiß nicht wie
oft der durch den führerschein gerasselt
ist glaubt 45 x oder so keine ahnung wie
er das geschafft hat
ach naja im skoda die zwei russen plus
cousins plus haben sich getrennt beide
haben jetzt eigene kanäle sind die
außenseiter würde ich sagen wir warten
auf die youtuber die angezeigt werden
und es sind die außenseiter denke das
war relativ klar ich will es jetzt
übrigens beim nächsten mal so machen
dass ich versuche nur anhand des ersten
merkmal zu erraten damit ist einfach ein
bisschen schwieriger wird und das erste
merkmale jetzt ist metro mädchenklasse
wir nehmen noch das zweite merkmal das
zweite merkmal ist studium wegen youtube
abgebrochen es ist baby glaube ich dass
dritte merkmal wäre gewesen eigene marke
rausgebracht ich glaube das bezieht sich
damit dann auch belohnt es ist wie dies
kritiker ist meine damen und herren das
hatte ich jetzt auch wieder richtig
bisher habe ich wirklich eigentlich alle
erwarten bis aufhalten wollte aber wir
haben auch sehr viele gemeinsamkeiten
check bitte auf jeden fall max barth
habe ich denke damit er halt andere
youtuber genommen haben das heißt es
definitiv schwerer weil hier halt die
bekanntesten sind also wie gesagt dass
unser in der beschreibung der sechzehnte
youtube vorgestellt wird war mit einem
youtuber zusammen
ok ich versuche jetzt mal nur anhand
dieses merkmal zu erwarten weil wir
vorhin schon bei da die wie das hatten
von fink war mit einem youtuber zusammen
und das heißt ja wenn sie zusammen waren
dass sie nicht mehr zusammen sind würde
ich jetzt sagen das ist lion tv ist aber
wir schauen uns jetzt erst mal die
nächsten merkmale das zweite merkmal ist
hat einen hund namens torres und
markenzeichen gleich löwe mit dem hund
keine ahnung aber machen zeichen löwe
kommt glaube ich hin das land ist und es
estland sieht blair der hat blaue haare
warum der 17 die youtuber hat als erstes
markenzeichen vollbart
[Musik]
apa/red hatten wir schon ich bin mir
nicht sicher jetzt nach dem ersten
merkmal
ich weiß noch nicht ob krank derzeitigen
vollbart hab ich nehme mal das zweite
merkmal noch hinzu also klein jeans
ich glaube ich lege mich auch changes
fest das dritte merkmal wäre gewesen
markenzeichen
bist du evtl
wann ich wusste wahl und wir haben das
gleich zeichen und das ist sturm macht
meine damen und herren
die rolle rollen sich ab und so das
waren alle absolut das war schon das
ende vom quiz respekt wenn das passieren
geschafft hast du natürlich danke für
deine zeit kein problem da hier der cool
dass du dieses quiz gemacht hat ich
hoffe euch hat dieses video gefallen
meine damen und herren setzt es getan
hat las man leichter ihr findet max park
und in der beschreibung verlinkt er hat
hier von den zweiten teil gemacht
vielleicht ist ja ein bisschen
schwieriger ich habe es auf jeden fall
zwei mal nicht geschafft die youtuber zu
erraten schreibe meine kommentare hier
ist die ganze zeit gewusst habe wer es
war und dann will ich sagen sie uns
morgen einen weiteren video wieder